Senator Chuck Grassley of Iowa is the
chairman of the Senate Judiciary
Committee he is leading the confirmation
hearings for judge Brett Kavanaugh and
Senator Grassley joins us now from
Washington good morning senator boy you
had your hands full yesterday yeah a
little bit different than other
committee meetings I've chaired and a
lot different than course such as an
example yes well absolutely well look I
know today will get much more down to
questions of substance as the senators
get to ask specific questions about how
Judge Cavanaugh may rule and his
temperament so let me ask you
specifically on the question question of
abortion rights do you believe the judge
Kavanagh would restore the authority of
states to regulate early term abortions
I think that when he's asked that
question and in fact I even advised him
yesterday
that he should go by the Ginsberg rule
that every nominee to the Supreme Court
sent since then when she was asked
specific questions about something that
becomes before the court she would say
there's not going to be any hints any
predictions no nothing because she it
isn't right for a candidate for the
Supreme Court to state to what their
views might be because then it would be
questionable about whether you're using
your own personal views or basing it on
the Constitution or the law and I think
you're going to see that answer from him
and then to answer your question that
you just asked me I would expect him to
give that answer okay
got it well as you know some believe
believe there is no constitutional right
to abortion so the question becomes with
Roe versus Wade why shouldn't this be a
legitimate form of questioning for him
to answer his views his legal views on
that question well yeah he will answer
very thoroughly I think but it's going
to be based upon the fact that he
doesn't know the specific facts of the
case he doesn't know the specific law
that might be full be before us because
right now if you know 50 states can have
50 different approaches to abortion
still within roe v wade that he may have
to make a ruling on
mr. chairman let me ask you a question
about about these documents you say it's
a process matter you say that the
Democrats haven't questioned these
qualifications but the documents are
about a period that Brett Kavanaugh
worked in politics when the questions in
the courts is how much politics gets
involved in laws so when Elena Kagan was
up before the committee everybody wanted
to know what she did during her time as
politics and Cavanaugh has said that
period is in many ways the most
instructive so if that period is
instructive to understanding his
jurisprudence why aren't Democrats right
to want more time to look into documents
from that period or to see documents
that haven't been turned over I think
that what Cavanaugh was saying it's very
instructive to him to to be a judge to
know what goes on in the executive
branch of government and he surely knew
what went on in the executive branch of
government because he had papers from
every cabinet member and every
intelligence agency and all that stuff
he had to decide what went to the
President or not to the president so I
interpret his station his statement is
meaning that he got very well educated
in the processes of the executive branch
so that makes him a better judge to make
decisions on on the law or the cases
that apply to the executive branch and
presidential power that's your reading
of it but you've heard me why shouldn't
Democrats get a chance to examine that
thinking based on the actual record and
not just having to guess about it yeah
because it's irrelevant to his being a
judge and not only that but remember
what Schumer and Leahy have said in the
past that the best judge of whether a
candidate should be on the Supreme Court
or not is where the cases they've
already heard in lower courts and this
person has 307 cases 10 or 11 thousand
pages that people can go by that's the
best judgment that Leahy and and Schumer
said for knowing whether somebody should
be on the Supreme Court if that's a rule
that you would use for sort of my heir
why wouldn't you use that same rule for
Cavanaugh well you got a lot of use out
of your gavel yesterday senator and
how do you intend to keep the calm today
what was your takeaway from yesterday
you know after senator McCain's funeral
there was a lot of calls for
bipartisanship
and that seemed to last a very short
time yesterday looking at what we saw in
your hearing room yesterday well I made
this statement yesterday that I think is
more true of what goes on in the United
States Senate and there's more
bipartisanship than what people see
we're very different on this judgeship
or judges generally Republican Democrats
differences but in the three-and-a-half
years that I've been chairman of the
committee every bill that has come out
of the Judiciary Committee has had
bipartisan support that speaks more
about how we work in a collegial way
than what you're seeing on television
senator in President Trump has called
jeff sessions said this guy is mentally
[ __ ] he's a dumb southerner
according to Bob Woodward's new book
would you support President Trump firing
his attorney general that's President
Trump's decision to make and I'll only
be involved in that is if he appoints a
new person all right Thank You senator
okay senator all right senator Grassley
thank you for being with us